رائع ، إنه لشرف كبير
أن أمنحك قميصًا لكرة القدم ، حسنًا ، فقط ما
يحتاجه زوجان من الرؤساء ، لكن كانت
هناك هدايا رئاسية أكثر إثارة
مثل زوج تنانين كومودو
الإندونيسي اليوم الرئيس جورج إتش دبليو
بوش ، الرئيس ري أهدى
السحالي إلى  حديقة حيوان سينسيناتي ، معظم
الأشياء التي تبلغ قيمتها أكثر من ثلاثمائة
وتسعين دولارًا ينتهي بها المطاف في الأرشيف الوطني ،
تلقى الرئيس ريغان 372
مشبكًا للحزام ومجموعة من السروج
بما في ذلك هذا السروج المزخرف من
الرئيس الجزائري رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
والرئيس أوباما الذي تعرض للجلد بشكل لا يُنسى
في كرة الطاولة
لذلك أعطى ديفيد كاميرون لأوباما طاولة بينج بونج
وتذكر أن كرة القدم التي
أعطاها الرئيس بوتين للرئيس ترامب
ستذهب إلى ابني بارون ، ليس لدينا أي
سؤال في الواقع ميلانيا هنا تذهب
للصحفيين في القمة ولاحظت أنني رأيت للتو
عميلًا في الخدمة السرية الأمريكية يضع  كرة القدم من
خلال ماسح أمني لكنهم
لم يحاولوا ذلك مع تنانين كومودو
حتى لو كانت مجرد وعاء من نبات النفل.
رئيس الوزراء الأيرلندي ، على
الرئيس أن يبدو مسرورًا إن لم يكن
يميل للفنانين الذين يميلون إلى إرسال
أشياء فريدة من نوعها مثل
كرسي باربرا بوش هذا ، صورة لريغان مصنوعة
من 10000 حبة جيلي وصورة
جون كنيدي منحوتة في الخوخ.
تلقى رئيس الحفرة كلينتون شخصية
بنفسه وهو يعزف على الساكس ، لكن عندما
أعطى زعيم أذربيجان آل كلينتون
صورهم على سجادة ،
ربما كان هذا هو المظهر على وجه الورقة النقدية الذي
يواجه هذه الهدية Just Peachy
Jeanne Moos CNN New York